boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are still at the raw Science Film
Festival fifth annual where we are
celebrating films that are making
tremendous impacts and waves in
civilization inspiring them in science
and technology we are now at Daniel
Solinger who is the director of
immortality or bust hello thank you for
joining us thank you for having me
really appreciate it and we really
appreciate your film your film is
incredible it's really good work and
we've had sultana's fun on the show
before that links in the bio to that
show this is very important the
transhumanist movement the ending aging
movement the hard work that it takes to
be at the cutting edge of teaching other
people about the importance of this tell
us about the journey well it's been a
long journey I just looked at my thing
so it's been a long journey I just
looked at my Instagram feed and I
realized that four years ago is when I
reached out to Zoltan and I said hey
you're running for president for the
transhumanist party that sounds
interesting and he wrote me back you
know like I basically said how can I
help and he said well you're a filmmaker
why don't you make a documentary about
it and then I went up to San Francisco
and I met with him and it's been it's
been quite a journey but but really
exciting and really fun
tell us on that on the story side of
things the importance of the
transhumanism the importance of ending
aging and getting more people into that
realm of thinking well I've been
following transhumanism since the early
90s like the very beginning and so I've
always been very excited about it and
it's been interesting seeing all these
technologies come online like CRISPR and
stuff that can actually bring a lot of
the things that transhumanist community
has been talking about for years to
actual reality and so I'm very excited
about it the fact that the sultan was
out there making it is meant you know
taking it mainstream may I always
wondered like when is politics going to
get involved in in the technology that's
that that's happening and you know so
Zoltan was somebody who was actually
taking it out making it popular making
wine street mainstream you know he was
you know definitely popularizing it he
you know and and so
the movie itself do I guess the question
is about the movie itself is that you
know it's if we follow the Zoltan this
von Ahn is a 2016 presidential campaign
and we go to biohacking labs
cryopreservation facilities
transhumanist churches you know all
sorts of places where you see you know
this this movement you know this this
very you know small but growing movement
you know happening and but unfortunately
at the same time Zoltan is struggling
with his dad's failing health and having
to juxtapose his his desire and passion
for the technology that would enable us
to radically extend life and seeing that
it's not coming online quick enough to
help his dad and that's that's what's
sort of the interesting tension in the
film yeah Daniel actually had me crying
when you did you had me crying because I
started really thinking about how if we
frame this as a point for youth and in
even adults and just tell them what
would it feel like if you were told that
you had an ailment that was uncurable
and that you were going to die within a
couple of weeks or months how would that
feel would you care about Science and
Technology then and so if we put this
frame of you or your parents or whomever
is has this ailment that's unsolvable
you would start caring so much about
science and technology to fix this
ailment you'd start hearing so much
about aging and radical life extension
etc so you went when when the result was
there with his father passed for me
that's what kicked in the sense of just
it's gonna be happening to so many
hundred plus thousand people under fifty
thousand a day die from aging around the
world and so um that was a very
important and you you gave this you you
went to cryogenic facilities biohacking
studios etc you you were totally there
showing people like we're already making
moves we just need more people involved
in trying new things and in getting
politics of all and involved and
entrepreneurs involved etc
that's true yeah I mean I've had the
experience like my father-in-law died
recently I had a nephew that died and
you know there's there's especially ever
since working you know on this film I
have such a sense of frustration and
sadness because I feel like if they
could just have hung on like another 20
like I feel sad for anybody who dies
right now because I feel like you know
in another 20 years it's going to be a
much more optional composition you know
it's going to be you know whatever
they're dying of now you know in 20
years there's going to be all this
technology and information to deal with
it you know so yeah it's it's it's it's
it's it's so nice actually to be alive
today but it's also so sad to see that
people die like right on the cusp of
like when all this technology is coming
online yeah I would like to ask you a
bit about you know distributions
obviously important so you guys are
aiming to distribute the film do you
have other ideas for what's coming next
for you as well yeah so yes I do
so this is our world premiere at the raw
Science Film Festival in 2019 and we are
I just put it out to sales agents who
help us in the selling process I've
produced 64 movies so I'm well
experienced in getting the movies out
there and in front of an audience and so
we have several sales agents interested
and then from that and then we're going
to go and play it a lot of more film
festivals and through that process of
going and playing more film festivals
and having a sales agent we will make
the right deal to get it in the widest
available places that that are possible
I love it and then other ideas for you
for the next upcoming well yeah I well I
have several other movies that are
either in post or you know yeah but
they're more narrative films but in
terms of I would love to do more work
specifically around the law of
accelerating returns and you know the
technologies that are coming online I
would love to do it I haven't even
talked to her about it but we over the
course of the movie we interviewed Liz
Parrish
I would love to do a movie on her and
what she's doing you know yeah yeah and
I know there's some footage maybe I'm
like shouldn't say this but there's some
footage of her like getting her tests
done or her initial injections done and
I don't know I'm sure your audience is
aware that she injected herself with a
retrofitted virus that lengthened her
telomeres which would be a huge thing in
terms of of defeating aging so and I
don't know if that's the movie but I'm
really open to doing more work in this
space I love it
I'm so happy that you care a lot about
the law of accelerating returns
exponential technology and highlighting
that and getting more people thinking
about that what do you think about the
current state of humanity like
geopolitically with all of the
exponential technology that's happening
well I mean first of all the you know
when I when I first started this project
with Zoltan I did a movie in the early
90s called rhymin reason that was about
hip hop and at the time hip hop was sort
of like a sub-genre just sort of like
you know like they wouldn't play hip hop
videos on MTV and it was it was a
different place and I said at that time
and then early 90s like I want to make a
documentary about hip hop because this
could be huge and end up being huge you
know obviously and I feel that way about
transfusing I like I when I when Zoltan
sit down make a movie about this I was
like yes because this is going to be an
enormous wave that's going to hit the
the the shores of popular culture
somewhere down the line I don't know if
it's five years I don't know if it's ten
years but it's it's coming and and the
exponential technology exponet the law
of accelerating returns and exponential
technologies they're going to happen you
know and like whether the popular
culture or politics or anybody you know
wants them to or not
you know I'm like I'm very into
cryptocurrency and you know like you
know there's a lot of bankers whatever
like Alta fat or whatever and like I
just know that they're going to get
wiped out the way Napster wiped out the
music business like like you know it's
just it's just coming they can deny it
or try to change it or try to control it
but it's so I just come and just you
know wipe out you know the whole
financial industry unless they adapt to
it you know and and I feel about that
way about all the other accelerating you
know technology is that you know it's
it's a force bigger than any sort of
political or
you know corporate you know control its
it's just it's gonna it's coming and
it's gonna be huge and I always tell
people I try to talk about this stuff
with people all the time and you know
like regular people they just look at me
crazy you know they're like all my
friends you know and you know my wife
you know like they all like what is this
guy talking about but it's going to
start to get really weird very soon like
it's it's starting to get weird but but
with the exponential growth you know
like when we when we have when we have a
is that passed the Turing test yeah like
it's gonna get so weird right exactly or
you haven't you now have a thousand
assistants because you've you can clone
that AI a thousand times and you can
have a thousand AI assistants that
understand everything that you want need
and just automatically do it for you
imagine what that worlds could be like
glad that you're bringing up all of
these pressing future aspects of
exponential technology that we really
have to have a global conversation about
how to best ethically morally
collectively move forward on on just
having conversation about what its gonna
be like stopping autonomous robots and
drones I'm hoping and and I don't want
to stay modest here but I really feel
like an hour movie Zoltan goes to the US
Capitol and reads a transhumanist Bill
of Rights it's really good and I think
there will be a day in history when
people are going to look back and say
that was the moment that was the moment
when politics started to when somebody
had the awareness that the world is
different than when human beings were
consistent
you know species you know and and I
don't know when that will be but I think
that I think it was like I think we
captured a moment in history that right
now I'm like there wasn't a big crowd
there but I think people will look back
because we were able to dock document it
and I'm going to say here's the first
true effort to change the structure the
political geopolitical structure to
understand and take into account cyborgs
argument artificial intelligence you
know and all these if issues yeah I'm so
happy that you brought that up because
those six articles of the transform
units bill of rights are you're right
this that was read at the start of the
inflection point and later
in a couple decades well that was it
that those were those first the first
time that they tried at the Capitol and
in DC its is it immortality' or bust
dot-com immortality' or bus comm the
links in the bio last question what's
the most beautiful thing in the world
well my wife and child that's what that
one's easy okay the most beautiful thing
in the world
inspiration creativity passion yeah
beautiful beautiful thank you so much
everyone go check out immortality your
bus it's super good it's super at the
cutting edge go and check it out Daniel
thank you for so much for coming onto
the show we greatly greatly appreciate
it everyone going build the future go
and manifest your destiny into the world
now much love and we'll see you soon
peace